اهلا بكم من جديد لا شك ان الصحه النفسيه
جزء لا يتجزا من الصحه العامه ومع ارتفاع
معدلات الاصابه بالاضطرابات النفسيه من
قلق واكتئاب وهي الاكثر شيوعا وغيرها من
الامراض النفسيه في الاونه الاخيره يجدد
اطباء الصحه النفسيه والخبراء بضروره
الاهتمام بالصحه النفسيه وتجنب مسببات
الاصابه باحد تلك الامراض الامراض النفسيه
هي عباره عن اضطرابات ذهنيه تختلف اثارها
من شخص الى اخر وتؤثر بشكل كبير على قدره
الاشخاص على العمل والانتاج والتعامل مع
الظروف ومع الاخرين
الاضطرابات النفسيه مشاهدينا تؤثر على شخص
واحد من كل ثمانيه اشخاص في العالم كما
انه كان هناك اكثر من 300 مليون شخص في
العالم مصابونه باضطراب القلق في عام 2019
والارقام في تزايد من عام الى عام
اذا نتابع الموضوع من القاهره مع الدكتوره
امل رضوان استاذته علم الاجتماع والعلاقات
الاسريه ومن عمان الدكتوره رشا التميمي
الاخصائيه النفسيه مرحبا بكما ضيفتي
الكريم الدكتوره رشا في عمان ابدا معك همم
لماذا صار الحديث بشكل كبير جدا عن
الاكتئاب وعن القلق وعن مضادات الاكتئاب
وعن الامراض النفسيه في هذه المرحله وهل
تراين ان هذا شيء جيد هذا وعيب المجتمعي
ام لا يعني هناك زياده كبيره همم في
الامراض النفسيه وبالتالي الصحه العقليه
والنفسيه في تدهور لدى البشر
اسعد الله مسائك اخي الكريم واسعد الله
مساء المشاهدين جميعا الان نعم هو في
تقريبا نستطيع القول انه الان نحن في صدد
صحوه صحوه نفسيه تجاه الطلبات النفسيه
تيجي تتجاهل للعلوم النفسيه ايضا بشكل عام
الان اصبح الوعي متزايد نظرا لانه طبيعه
حياتنا تختلف عن طبيعه الحياه السابقه
لان وثيره الحياه سريعه
المتطلبات المطلوبه من كل شخص فينا حتى لو
كان صغير او كبير متطلبات كبيره يمكن انها
تضعف ضغط نفسي اصبح الان ااه البحث عن
متنفس او البحث عن مفهوم او يعني ان يفهم
الانسان ماذا يحل به من همم
امراض او حتى اعراض او بدايه بوادر اضطراب
نفسي اصبحت ضروره ملحه لانه همم يؤثر على
انتاجته كشخص يؤثر على علاقات ويؤثر على
حياته بشكل عام والصحه النفسيه هو كما
ذكرت ليس جزء من صحه الجسم
والصحه المهنيه
دكتوره امل اهلا بك معنا من جديد يعني مع
مرارنا به في كورونا وكذلك الان مع
التابعات الحرب الاوكرانيه والظروف
الاقتصاديه الصعبه والضغوط العمل قد يكون
المر انه طبيعي انه احيانا الواحد يشعر
انه نفسيته تعبانه او انه يمر بيوم سيء او
بانه لا يريد الذهاب للعمل او بانه قلق
على مستقبله ومستقبل اطفاله متى يمكن
الحكم بانه لا هذا اكتئاب يجب ان نذهب الى
الدكتور او هذا قلق مرضي يجب ان اتابعه او
ربما يشك انه لديه مرض نفسي عليه التوجه
فضلت اكيد كلنا بنمر زمان مشاكل ضغوط بلا
شعار معهد الغضب بالحزن بالاكتئاب دي
مشاعر طبيعيه
اخذت وقت الطبيعي بتاعها قدرنا ان احنا
نتخطاها ولكن في علامات بتدل ان انا ده مش
مجرد حزن عادي او قلق عادي لا ده تطور
الامر الى اضطراب نفسي اا من العلامات دي
هي فكره ان انا اكون يعني تقلبات مزاجيه
شديده ممكن ان هو يكون اا فرح مبالغ فيه
حزن مبالغ في الموقف لا يستدعي ده همم
طبعا السلوكيات العاديه والعنيفه همم
بتاثر كمان على
حياته على عمله على دراسته بنلاقي ان حصل
همم تغير في سلوكيات وتغير في اداءه كمان
اضطرابات النوم من العلامات اللي بتبقى
واضحه جدا ان في مشاكل نفسيه حتى اضطرابات
الاكل اللي بنقول عليها فقدان الشهيه او
حتى شراها في الاكل كل دي علامات بتدل
الافكار الانتحاريه اللي ده طبعا تدل كمان
على تدهور الحال او ان في مشكله نفسيه
شديده طيب دكتور امل هنا سؤالي يعني
الاعراض التي عدتها ربما قد يشعر بها
الكثير من المشاهدين الان الذين يستمعون
الينا اذا كان الرغبه في الاكل همم يعني
الشعور بالحزن تقلبات المزاج ولكن همم متى
يمكن الحكم باللي بانه هناك يعني هناك مرض
نفسي يجب التواجد الطبيب الافكار
الانتحاريه هي يعني هي اكبر اكبر دليل ام
لا
بالتاكيد هي اختارها يعني هي اخطر حاجه هي
فكره ان الشخص يبتدي يفكر في الانتحار او
حتى مش بس اذا نفسه ممكن ازاء الاخرين
لانه الموضوع ده يستمر الفتره طويله مش
مجرد ما هو طبيعي كلنا بعد الازمات او
المشاكل الممر بمرحله شويه من الاحباط
القلق الفوبيا الخوف ولكن فكره ان ده
يستمر لفتره طويله هو هنا دمه مؤشر خاصه
يعني العلماء ما حددوهاش بالفتره محدده
ولكن الحزن الطبيعي اللي هو بيبتدي مع
الوقت يقل يعني بنبتدي ان احنا نعود
لحياتنا كمان لما بنلاقي ان في تاثير على
الشغل او على الدراسه تاخر في الدراسه او
تاخر في العمل كمان التشتيت او عدم
التركيز لفترات طويله هنا لا في مؤشر خطر
وكمان مش بس الشخص هو اللي يلحظ ده
المحيطين به كمان طيب دكتوره رشا التميمي
في عمان بيتنا في عصر نبحث فيه عن الحلول
السريعه همم والجاهزه همم والعلم تطور
كثيره وهناك نظريات كذلك تتحدث على انه
المرض النفسي مثله مثل الانفلونزا هو خلل
في كيمياء الدماغ وبالتالي هو يحتاج الى
ادويه بشكل مباشر هل الادويه مفيده لعلاج
الامراض النفسيه ام لا
نعم الادويه مفيده في تقريبا معظم الحالات
التي تعاني من اضطرابات نفسيه طبعا
باختلاف الدرجه وباختلاف المسببات ولكن
انا دائما بحب انوه واكد انه الدوا لوحده
نعم يساعد على كما ذكرت على يعني تحسين
النقل العصبيه والهرمونات وكيميائيه الجسم
ولكن لا غنى عن العلاج النفسي لعلاج
المعرفي السلوكي الجلد السلوكي
وانواع العلاجات الاخرى لانه همم الدواء
يرتبط بكميائيه الجسم لكن هناك عامل اخر
ما يسمى بالعامل السلوكي الذي احنا نريد
ان نكسب المريض او المراجع الان مهارات
سلوكيه الانقيه من الانتكاسه اذا اذا حدث
من مواقع مشابهه يعرف كيف يتصرف معها في
المستقبل في الاضافه لانه نعمل على همم
بيحكوا عليها دائما
على البيئه
الدكتوره همم
انه ال- المفيد هو همم ان تكون هناك
علاجات بالادويه هناك ادويه مثلا مضادات
اكتئاب وان يكون هناك علاجات يعني جلسات
مع متخصص نفسي تكون في همم علاجات سلوكيه
صحيح طبعا طبعا الحالات التي يعطي الطبيب
فيها الطبيب النفسي ان الادويه ما بتكون
جميع الحالات احيانا بتكون فقط جلسات علاج
معرفه سلوكي او علاج للسلوكي كلاميا
ويستفيد جدا همم
الادويه والعلاج المعرفي السلوكي كم كم
المده اللازمه همم للشخص الذي يعاني نفسيا
كم المده العلاج كم كم همم مدتها
هلا حسب شده الاضطراب حتى كما ذكرت لك في
بعض الاضطرابات وبعد مشكلات نفسي لا تحتاج
الى دواء نكتفي فقط في الجلسات تكون شده
وحيده الاضطراب خفيفه او اقل من المتوسط
فاذا كانت متوسط واعلى حين نحتاج الى
الجمع ما بين الجلسات والادويه والبعض
يحتاج الى عشر جلسات لبعض يحتاج الى 20
لبعض
علاجه كما ذكرت الدكتور اذا كان في افكار
انتحاريه واداء للذات والاخرين ممكن يحتاج
من ست اشهر الى سنه واحيانا بعض الحالات
اكثر فحسب الحاله وحسب شدتها وحسب العوامل
وهمم هناك ما يسمى الرزق فاكثر زوامل
الخطوره اللي هي موجوده كم لازالت موجوده
ما هي هذه العوامل
العوامل الخطوره ممكن تكون انه مسببات
لازالت موجوده من اشخاص محيطين مسيئين
للشخص لازم موجودين في حياته او احيانا
ضغوطات في المهنه ضغوطات عمليه لازالت
موجوده في حياته احيانا افكار ممكن ان
لازالت تراود ولم يشفى منها بعد الدكتوره
امل في القاهره طبعا اذا كان مثلا هناك
ضغوط مهنيه وهذه الضغوط تسبب اكتئاب ماذا
يفعل المراه يترك عمله يعني لا هذا ليس
حلا ما رايك ما ما الحل
اكيد
يعني هو بدايتها المفروض ان هو يحاول ان
هو يتكيف وكلنا نبقى فاهمين ان اكيد دائما
العمل في ضغوط في مشاكل في بعض الصراعات
مع الاسف بتبقى متواجده في العمل فيبقى
مهين نفسيا ان احنا نحاول ان احنا نتكلم
العمل في عمل اخر ده يبقى كويس جدا ان انا
اقلل من الضغط لكن لو ده غير متاح يبقى
انا احاول ان انا اتكيف احاول ان انا اشوف
ايه اللي هيساعدني على تخطي الازمات او
المشاكل هل في خطا او تقصير من عندي ابتدي
ان انا اصلحه هل في مشاكل من الاخرين
ابتدي ان انا اتجنب تلك المشاكل يعني
المهم الواحد يحدد سبب المشكله الرئيسي
عشان اقدر ان انا اتعامل معه الدكتوره امل
طيب الوقايه من الامراض او الاضطرابات
النفسيه كيف تكون هناك من يقول انه
الرياضه تساعد هناك من يقول انه الروحانيه
اذا كان صلاه اذا كان يوغا اذا كان همم
يعني ممارسه نشاط التحدث مع الاخ بناء
علاقات اجتماعيه كيف يمكن ان نقي انفسنا
من الاضطرابات النفسيه
مهم جدا اهو
بالروحاني عندي مهم ان انا اغذيه جدا ان
انا الجا لربنا ان انا اكون باتمتع بالرضا
يعني في كل الاحوال ان انا اكون راضي عن
الوضع اللي انا عايش فيه مهم جدا ان انا
اكون في حاجه باعملها انا باحبها في حياتي
سواء كانت ممارسه رياضه ده شيء مهم جدا
حتى فكره المشي يوميا اللي هي اسهل رياضه
حتى على كبار السن ده مهم لان هو بيخرج
التقاط السلبيه اللي موجوده عند الانسان
المهم جدا ان انا اخذ قسط كافي من النوم
اكل اكل غذاء صحي متوازن العلاقات
الاجتماعيه مهمه جدا جدا في حياه الانسان
هتساعده كثير قوي على تخطيط تلك الازمات
همم ان الانسان يشغل وقت فراغه بما هو
يفيده ان انا احاول انا يعني اخرج نفسي من
الحالات النفسيه السلبيه او المشاكل اللي
انا عايش بقدر الامكان برده ال- همم
اليوجا وتمارين التامل وكل الحاجات دي
بتساعد على الاسترخاء وتصفيه البيت
وتخليصه من كل الضغوط والمشاكل فكره ان
انا اعمل كمان عمل تطوعي ده من الحاجات
ايجابيه جدا اللي ممكن تخلي الانسان يتخلص
من المشاعر السلبيه اللي موجوده جواه تجنب
قدر الامكان ال- ايه الظروف اللي بتحطني
تحت ضغط مع الاسف الانسان هو اللي يعني اه
يعني احاول ان انا اتجنبها لو بايدي ان
انا اتجنبها في طبعا حاجات مش بيدي ان انا
اتجنبها ولكن قدر الامكان احاول ان انا
اتجنب احاول ان انا اكون علاقات
الاجتماعيه
متنوعه وفيها تنزه وفيها سفر فيها همم نعم
تفضل شكرا جزيلا لكما كذلك الموضوع شيخ
ومهم جدا شكرا على هذه المعلومات التي همم
اثريتم بهذا النقاش شكرا لك الدكتور امل
رضوان استاذه تعلم الاجتماع من القاهره
والدكتوره رشا التميمي الاخصائي النفسيه
من عمان شكرا جزيلا لك مشاهدينا شكرا لكم
على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء